I have an idea for you so I call this my
new lambda school idea
have you ever do you guys have like an
office administrator or office admin I
don't know if you guys are we have yeah
I mean we have someone who handles stuff
yes I do sar and things like that right
I'm talking more like so admin work or
like an executive assistant or secretary
do you have anybody like that have you
ever so recently I'm at my work we're
hiring an EI right so we had any a she
left we had to hire a new executive
assistant and so they put me on the
hiring panel and I'm like ok I don't
know what questions I'm supposed to ask
like I don't really know what the
background I should be looking for all
that stuff so I started thinking about
this store looking it up so it turns out
that office administrators or
secretaries or any or executive
administrators EA's it's one of the most
popular jobs in the country and it's
also something where so there's about
you know I'd say 600,000 I think in the
US and they pay pretty well so it
doesn't require tons of specialized
skill that's pretty much anybody can
learn to do this if you're you know
somewhat competent but you can make 50
60 70 80 K doing this I thought that's a
pretty good paying job and I know at our
company the EI is they're critical they
do such an amazing job they they're they
help and all the senior leaders do what
they do and so I started looking about
this and I said could there be a lambda
school for EA's because I think this is
something that in three months you could
teach people the core skills that you
need around calendaring booking travel
you know note taking all the different
sort of core components that you need to
do to do this job well you know it's not
rocket science you just need to learn
the tools and learn the sort of do's and
don'ts and then I think companies when
you know like us when we're hiring for
this there's no like school or degree
that you look at or you like oh because
you have this degree you're gonna do a
good job and so it's usually like do you
already have experience doing this or
not but that's a catch-22 because how do
you break in if everyone wants to hire
for somebody who already has experience
doing it and so I'm thinking that you
could create a pro
that tells it offers people who says hey
in three months we can train you for a
job that'll pay you 50 60 or 70 K here
and it's a job that has good you know
work-life balance and all this other
characteristics of it and so and you
could use the lambda school model where
you take an income share agreement you
say great on training people for three
months
it cost me three thousand dollars to do
this remote virtual school but I make
back you know up to fifteen K 17 K per
candidate that gets placed into a job
over time what do you think of this idea
[__] love it and I'm looking it up
right now
org org dot Co I'm your dove or gorg no
we use it let's see how big their team
is that can kind of tell us something
they are but okay what or org is is it's
a community / community / job board it's
something um I don't know how you would
describe it in one word it's a organ org
is a 100% volunteer run organization we
have job or blogs resources we have
private groups and email lists and it's
all for HR and my executive assistant
office manager HR departments a DIY
admin assistant like you know reverence
its and so my our old ei was on this and
it was an email list and and they would
send out blasts like hey I'm looking for
the best
IIT person our company small we only
have a budget of $2,000 who do you
recommend or like when I wanted to hire
new ei I had a friend post a listing on
there and I got tons of applicants what
I would do with your idea is I would
either buy this company
man these these the lady who runs this I
forget her name but she could be making
millions off of this but I don't think
she is I bet she's making hundreds of
thousands of dollars so like I would buy
that yeah I would buy that I had or
become the platinum sponsor for you know
fairly fair rate and use it for the sort
of the user acquisition and there's this
powerful thing because once you build
the brand that hey yeah this is it's
like a staffing agency right but it's a
it's a big internet internet version of
a staffing agency and once you place
some people to good things
the first is you get a reputation that
says hey reas I've been hired by company
ABCDE and if we could come may become a
trustworthy source for good EA's but
then also right now all the candidates
in our current be a pipeline came from
our existing pas people they knew from
their network and so as your alumni
become your hiring become your hiring
partners and so the more alumni you
place the more opportunities you have
for your own graduates and so I think
that's like the real power of the lambda
school model and unlike okay so the
ladies go model you gotta break that
[__] down labor school model you're
saying and you train them for free and
then you get a percentage of their
salary yes you love that model for
everything not for everything
necessarily but I think when you have a
low cost of training it's a great model
because it reduces the friction to join
because you say well it's free and so I
only I only have to pay them if I get a
high paying job out of this so your
incentives are aligned right because we
want you to get a high paying job and
you came to us to get a high paying job
we only get paid if you get a paying job
and if you get a high paying job this is
a reasonable payback for for us
providing that service to you and so I
think anyway any place where you have a
low cost of training this is a very good
mechanism it's not just a dent mechanism
it gets a lot of hype but really it's
just a debt vehicle and but I think it's
a good debt vehicle for this
[Music]